[Music]
Merry Christmas Gotham City in breaking
news Gotham is officially Crime Free as
Batman continues to clean it
up Dad I'm ready to be a superhero like
you
woohoo Merry Christmas
kiddo my own utility belt which should
only be used in case of a bat emergency
oh come on dad I'm not a baby hey I
never said you were a baby emergency
call for help my precious little baby is
in
danger it's the Justice
League sorry Damien I got to go shall I
assume we did not see the bat Razer I
like it totally UPS my intimidation game
you have donut crumbs in your
intimidation
games I promise I'll be back before
Christmas oh man I'm the worst dead
ever Jingle Bells bman Smells Robin L
egg Joker oh how I want to make this a
very special Christmas Eve and what
better way to do it than by stealing
Christmas I have to show Dad I can
handle myself wo it's a bit saggy well
that one just leaves nothing to the
imagination dad made me a bat suit
awesome wait until they get a load of
me you don't have what it takes to be a
superhero I can do this I'm saving
Christmas all right which one of you
gave a little kid
explosives allow me to break the ice
little Batman everybody in here what do
you say need a wing man
more like
a
sidekick
[Music]
ch